it's a little trick that we try to
pretend that we're important goddamn it
just look up at the sky and although you
can't see it there are stars that are
being swallowed up by black holes yeah
like if the universe doesn't give a [ __ ]
about something that's a million times
bigger than the earth yeah why would you
think he gives a [ __ ] about you it's
eating stars that's a terrible question
most people that's a terrible insulting
question the problem you know that's
kind of what who was it Albert Camus the
French existentialist and Sartre and all
those guys they were saying like Camus
said the fundamental question is why
wouldn't you why not just commit suicide
because everything is totally absurd and
nothing means anything right it's like
the rock of Sisyphus that you keep
pushing up and it keeps rolling down and
then he said but but the truth is most
people don't want to kill themselves but
they'll commit philosophical suicide
meaning instead of like really starting
to ask these questions and really
getting into it and realizing that it's
all hopeless and despair you know you
you just you just go on to a certain
philosophy that gives you hope religion
yeah or whatever it might be which is
what it is and maybe the way out of that
is just to enjoy every day taste your
food enjoy your friends and realize that
it could end in any in any second you
know one another thing that's [ __ ]
with me the concept of reincarnation not
the concept of reincarnation like coming
back as a butterfly or something like
that but the concept of living your life
over and over and over again until you
get it right Jesus
now here's what [ __ ] with me I am
having a great time so why wouldn't I
want to do this again yeah I'm having a
great time I have great friends like you
and young Jamie over the Aaron I have I
love my family
I love what I do for a living I love our
circle of friends is amazing I mean we
are for sure some of the luckiest men I
have ever met in my life there's no
doubt there's no doubt we have fun man
dude I was thinking about all the
mistakes I've made but then I went wait
a minute but I'm here like at 52 I'm
here I've made like [ __ ] loaded mistakes
where we are but we're also risk takers
I mean we're professional performers we
wanted to a job that has zero job
security
[ __ ] headfirst no safety net
dove right in you know we make mistakes
we make mistakes with our our job we
make mistakes with our personal life and
make mistake with it's just no women no
ever because because I don't have a
dress rehearsal I'm presented with these
I'm presented with the scenario I have
to make a choice in real time yeah I'm
gonna make a mistake right and and once
I realize that and stop beating myself
up about it and realize that I'm I've
always done the best I can but here's
where you here's what you can do be
brutally honest and assess yourself and
see where you're falling short and then
just change your approach yeah so that's
kind of what I did when I saw acting
when I saw what just being an actor was
and I saw how precarious it was I saw
where the business was moving with like
new media and stuff and I was like this
doesn't make I would then I watched you
doing your podcast and you would say
stratified so guess what I started a
podcast didn't go well
start another podcast didn't make money
then start a third podcast with friend
and shop and blah blah blah but you know
it's same thing with stand-up you just
keep doing it yeah you keep following
the models that works I was doing the
wrong thing over here and next thing you
know you know you got a grind
that's where a lot of comics [ __ ] up but
they do it like once a week and then
they take a few weeks off and then come
back and do it again and they're like
how do you do it all the time I'm like
because I know how to grind I'm a
grinder it's not just grind like for me
the idea is original self-expression I'm
interested in trying to take the way I
think so a lot of things scare me and
they make me angry and I don't know how
to how to react but you know instead of
fretting about it I create you know
Michelangelo my favorite quote
criticized by creating didn't great
[ __ ] crow he said that's beautiful
yeah he said that he said criticized by
creating I always think about that
because that's kind of when I look at my
body of work in the progression of my my
specials for example like man class
little too you know just about being
funny and a silly goose then never grow
up a little more personal about my dad
but then this last one complicated Apes
is that out right now it's out right now
oh my god is this the number one iTunes
comedy out
the rankings apparently it's crushing
and weird it's number one in the world
where you can rent and buy I guess
complicated Apes it's doing very well if
you want to get it and laugh hard and
learn feel like we should celebrate
listen this is not one this is not about
promoting my special feel like we should
feel you should promote it a little bit
alright fine get complicated Dave let's
just get out right now right I guess
it's out right now get it on iTunes or
anywhere you like aerial TV could just
watch it on your you get it on Xbox or
Playstation you can listen up you can
get on Amazon I don't stop